the Joe Rogan experience I almost killed
my cousin like that two times I've
watched people almost die on drugs that
I was with the one that scared me was my
cousin we found out my cousin Timmy is
he's allergic to it's got to be THC he's
allergic to weed it just destroys I mean
up like that will [ __ ] turn him gray
and so this is what I what we didn't
know so his younger sister had had she
was turning 19 I think it was and I'm
living with them at the time my
grandmother just passed away and I don't
have a place to stay and her sister my
aunt Marguerite took me in and I'm
living with them and my cousin
Jennifer's like I'm having a birthday
party tonight at the house the girls are
all gonna come back here right so my we
get some good weed from Oregon you did
was rare to get good [ __ ] bud from
the west coast in the early you know let
the 90s regularly and you've always got
we call it a practice wheat that's what
we always [ __ ] got but this [ __ ] came
and I rolled one all was beautiful it
just had a pencil point to a while we're
smoking it I was like let's it's
February it's so [ __ ] cold that would
that bone show cold I'm like let's go
sit in my car I'm gonna smoke this joint
I had a 1990 Honda Civic with original
rims bro we're in there [ __ ] smoking
we're listening to Hendrix and he takes
one hit and he goes let me have one more
I'm like you should and you remember
that he's like let me I'm like this is
really strong weeds let me have one more
hits one more so we get out of the car
and he's like just standing up and he's
got his hand he looks like he just stole
second he's got his hands on his knees
he's breathing heavy and Shay's I'm like
all right let's go get back inside and
I'm walking down the driveway and I
remember visually seeing that gust of
wind come around the corner of the house
and just plant itself in my [ __ ]
chest so I get the [ __ ] shakes it's
like two degrees outside
ah we go in the house and we're just
start throwing thermals and [ __ ] on and
as I'm doing I'm looking at him and I'm
like hey man you don't look you don't
look so good he's like oh he's touching
himself in the mirror he's turning gray
start sweating
[ __ ] feel good I'm like go upstairs
and get some water right now
and it progressed so quickly and he
looked like [ __ ] so bad that I'm over in
the mirror looking at myself like I'm
like I'm okay I'm fine I go out to come
to tell my cousin his sister what
happens and there's a fireplace fires
going I'm sitting next to her and we're
just warming up and I'm like he goes
what she goes what the [ __ ] my brother
over there I go we just went out in the
car we got high and he's [ __ ]
freaking out she goes well there's 19
girls here and 17 of us are tripping on
acid right now I go there's two girls
scared of the other group locked in the
bathroom okay he comes back down the
stairs and he's just four he's battling
for life at this point he's trying to
get in the bathroom they think it's the
girls on acid so they're not letting
anyone in he's he just turns around and
at the time we're watching I'm like look
at him look at him now and he just takes
two steps and he stands erect and just
rocks back and goes face for it into the
banister he crashed bust his face open
he lays on the ground he starts having
like a little seizure I'm like oh my and
I'm where you are I'm like oh my god I
just [ __ ] killed him Friday had just
come out my cousin on point jumps on top
of them it's like you got knocked the
[ __ ] out they all start laughing I'm
like by the way my aunt and uncle
they're asleep upstairs I'm like oh my
god his eyes are rolling back in his
head
this one girl grabs the [ __ ] phone to
call 9-1-1 she hits nine she hits one
I've already got his head tilted I'm
ready to go I'm very good in controlled
chaos and I'm just I'm about to [ __ ]
put my mouth I can't believe I got to
get my cousin and they're all laughing
they're on acid they don't they think
it's hilarious I go to put worried about
this clothes and get the [ __ ] off of me
and I was like don't hit while I was
like oh gotta go what the [ __ ] I because
I was I was locked inside myself I heard
everything you said I couldn't respond
though I heard everything right I was
stuck inside myself he had come out now
his teeth are through his lip here
because he's hit the banister and the
chicks on acid now see the blood and now
they start freaking off I'm like Oh
seventeen girls of nineteen I'm like I'm
not taking you to the hospital we can't
go to the hospital tell them we've got a
bunch of kids on
and all and I was like you just gotta
suck it up and tough it out so he waited
till the morning then got my uncle cuz
it just busted his lip all up and he was
like I just tripped down the steps and
hit the banister but that was the second
time that we almost killed his he did a
gravity balling one time out of the
kitchens sake I really thought he was
gonna die I'm like why would you ever
touch weed again
[Applause]